Christian Grey is supposed to be this /
- this guy who works out a lot takes
really good care of himself but
apparently you guys didn't want to do
the standard you and the director talked
about we don't want to just show him
like lifting weights we want to be a
little more interesting in that that's
true because yeah they want to have a
scene of him like working oh and if he
was just lifting weights he'll be too
boring and right when I have them you
know it's a higher sort of thing so I
just happened to say or like I've got
this like one party trick that I can do
but I need like a sort of pommel horse
right a gymnastics yeah yeah yeah you
know there's like suede you know guys so
that's what they arranged for me and I
was like okay look we've got you've got
one take to get this because it is it's
so hard to do and I try to do and I
don't really know why I can do it but um
we did it and I would say just make sure
everything's in focus and there's enough
film in the camera and we're gonna do
this once and then I'm gonna need like a
rest in my choice so I'm really I have
not seen it I'm curious to know what it
is is it anything you could possibly
recreate here
okay I don't want you to get hurt or
anything so if you're not feelin it
don't do this such about it
I don't know what's gonna happen now is
this this just before I do this yeah if
my face break chiming you will pay for
all that like myself I will not
personally pay for it that's something
that Andy's on the hook for we go I'll
be out of here
[Applause]
I am almost lino exaggerating I just
pulled my pack you just put your pack as
a little injured there yeah that's not
good okay oh sorry little look at it
look at it look in it Cooper okay
hey boy it's worth the broken tip yeah
totally worth Andy we don't call it a
broken tip oh sorry I hope you all right
we'll get you medical attention right
afterwards if anything's gone wrong as I
said Andy's on the hook for it
you